hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve
find median from a data stream so this
is another
hard problem but it's not super
difficult if you know the data structure
behind it
so they basically tell us we know the
median is defined as the middle value
in a sorted integer list if the list is
even there is no middle value so you
take the average of the two middle
values right
so with this sorted array the middle
value is three so the median is three
with this there is no middle value so
you take the two middle values
add them together divide by two and then
you get a median of 2.5
and so we're actually designing a data
structure that's going to have two
operations
one operation is going to be adding a
number to our data stream so we had
we actually have to store the list of
numbers and that list of numbers is not
constant it's going to be changing every
time
add number is called and then from that
list of numbers that we're going to be
maintaining ourselves
we are going to need to constantly be
finding the median
of that list so every time this function
find
median is called we have to return what
the median is
from the elements so far so this is just
an example
if we add num1 then our list is going to
have one in it
if we add another number two then our
list is going to have two numbers
then if we want to find the median we
will take the average of these two and
it's going to be
1.5 after that we'll add another number
three
and then we'll find the median again in
this case the median is different
because our list got updated the middle
value is now
two so what's the most obvious way to
solve this problem well i
basically just hinted at it right so
where
the way the obvious way to solve this is
insert elements
in order so let's say these are the
function calls that are gonna be made so
we're gonna add
four numbers and then we're gonna try to
get the median so we're gonna maintain
a list or an array right and
every time we get a function call add
three
we're gonna insert in order just like it
says up here
and basically if our array is always
sorted
then it's going to be easy to identify
the middle number right which is going
to be the median
right so the median is always going to
be in the middle position and if our
array is sorted we'll always know where
that
is so the first one we have is add three
so just add it to the first spot
next we want to add two so how do we do
that in order well
we have to traverse our array so far so
we get
we see that there's a three over here
right so then we gotta replace that
three we shift the three to the next
position and then we put a
two in the position that the three was
initially at
right so now our array is in sorted
order we had to
uh shift some elements and we had to
search for the spot that we put the two
in right so you can tell that every time
we add a number
it's going to be an o of n operation
where
n is the number of elements we have
added so far
so we added two next let's add one
well we're gonna traverse the array
right we're gonna see okay the first
element is two we know that
one is less than two so really what
we're gonna do is
cross out the two cross out the three
right shift the two over here
shift the three over here and then put a
one here but
i'll just to keep the picture simple i'm
just gonna put the one over here but we
know that
in the worst case every time we insert
an element it's gonna be o of
n lastly we're gonna take the four and
add the four so we're gonna see
one nope four is bigger than that two
nope four is bigger than that three
nope four is bigger than that so we add
the four at the end
so now we finally have a get median call
well good thing for us since our
array is in sorted order we know getting
the median is super easy in this case we
have an
even length list right we have four
elements so we are going to take
the two middle elements two and three
add them together
divide by two we're going to get 2.5 so
we know that
the get median operation is always going
to be o of 1
but adding a number is always going to
be o of n
so how can we speed this o of n
operation up and let me just tell you
basically what we're going to do
is instead of having just a single list
of
elements we're gonna break this up into
two and
the we're gonna have basically two
subsets right
and one is always gonna be less so this
has one
and two and this has three and four
and all elements from the left are
always going to be
less than or equal to all elements in
the right
so this will also make it easy for us to
get the median
but i'm not just gonna have arrays i'm
going to use a
heap or a priority queue so we're going
to use a heap data structure
so i'm going to have two heaps in this
case a small heap and a large heap
small heap all elements in the small
heap are always going to be less than or
equal to
all elements in the large heap also
the size of these heaps is always going
to be approximately equal so
if there were two elements in this heap
then there's there has to be two
elements in this heap what if we had an
odd number of elements so what if there
were three elements in this heap
that's allowed because we know that we
can't actually
have these be equal if there's a two and
a three right
or in the opposite case there could be
two elements here and there could
actually be
three elements here that's also allowed
because we know that's approximately
equal
if the difference though is ever greater
than one so if there were
four here and two here we know then we
have to balance them right make this
equal
three and make this equal three right we
always have to keep it as balanced as
possible
and if you're not familiar with what
exactly a heap is
it's basically like a list it's pretty
similar to a list it's implemented
using arrays or lists the only
difference is though
adding a number we don't add at the
beginning or at the end we just
add elements to the heap and adding an
element to this
heap is always going to be a log n
operation
and removing an element is also going to
be
a log n operation right so add
or remove is log n and there happen to
be
two kinds of heaps a max heap or
a min heap and the thing about these
is so for a max heap finding the max
in this list so find max in a max heap
is always going to be
o of one so that's the advantage
we know that finding the max in a
regular list
is o of n because you have to search the
entire list
but with a heap we can find the max in
constant time
similarly with a min heap if you want to
find the min
that's also an o of one operation
so with that being said the small heap
is going to be implemented as a
max heap and the reason we have a max
heap and not a min heap it's kind of
counterintuitive right if this is the
small heap why are we using a
max heap and that for this one we're
actually going to have a
min heap instead of a max heap
and the reason is what if we had
elements to
these heaps such as right what if we had
these elements in each of the heaps
right we see that all elements here are
less than or equal to the elements in
the
right heap but if you actually want to
find the median
of these we know we need to get the max
value in the small heap right two and we
need to get the
min value in the large heap three
add them together and then divide by two
right that's how we're going to get the
median so that's why we need the min
heap right
we always want the minimum value from
our large heap and we always want the
max value from our small heap and of
course
finding the median like this way right
getting the
value getting the value from each of the
heaps it only works
if the size of the heaps is
approximately the same right if
in this case they're equal but what if
we had a
third element in this heap what if we
had a three well they're approximately
equal right but you can see the length
of this one
is greater right but the difference in
length is one so they're approximately
equal
in that case how are we going to find
the median well since we know that the
length of this heap is bigger than the
length of this heap
we know that we have an odd number of
elements in that case right if one heap
is bigger than the other there's
always going to be an odd number and in
that case we're going to want to get the
value
from this heap so if the length of this
heap
is bigger we're going to want to get the
max from
here we're going to want to get the max
value from this heap and that's going to
be
3 and we know in this case 3 happens to
be the median right if you
because look at them these values are in
sorted order we get rid of these two we
get rid of these through
two the middle value is three and i'm
not going to walk you through this case
but
let's just say imagine we had a two over
here the exact same thing would happen
right we would get the min value from
here we get the two
and notice that look the max value from
here and the min value from here are
equal right that's why i say
every value in here has to be less than
or equal it's possible that they are
equal
okay so now let me just go through a
quick walkthrough of this code again
so what we're gonna do add the first
element which is a three
which heap are we gonna add it to in
this case it doesn't really matter so
what i'm gonna do is just by default add
it to the small heap
so let's add three to the small heap and
we know that that was roughly a log
n operation right next let's add
two so by default i'm always gonna take
whatever element we add and i'm gonna
take it and add it to the small heap now
i added
two to the small heap but wait a minute
now the heaps are not approximately
equal
this has a length of two this has a
length of zero it was okay when this had
a length of one because that's still
approximately equal
but 2 is that's too big of a difference
so now what we're going to do is find
the max
value in this heap and add it to
this heap the large heap which is always
going to have elements greater than or
equal to the small heap
so we need to get the max value from
this heap and since this is a max heap
actually finding the maximum is an o of
one
operation now the downside is we have to
remove
that value which is a log n operation
and we're going to take that element
that we removed and add it
to the min heap and that's also going to
be a
log n operation we know adding and
removing
from heaps is always login finding the
maximum in a max heap
is o of one finding the minimum in a min
heap is also o of one
okay so now we did add three add two now
let's add
one i'm gonna change this add one to a
add
seven just to illustrate one last thing
about this
algorithm that we're gonna do and let me
just cross this out we're not doing
insert order anymore we're doing the
heap solution
so we're gonna add seven right by
default
i know that i'm adding it to the small
heap so what am i gonna do i'm gonna
take
seven and add it to the small heap now
the size of this heap is two the size of
this heap is one so they are
approximately equal the last condition
though
is every element in the small heap less
than or equal
to every element in the min heap now how
are we going to check that well
we can find the minimum of the min heap
in o of one time
right it happens to be three we can find
the max of the small heap in o of one
time
it happens to be seven is that
is seven less than or equal to three no
it's not so
what are we gonna do well we're actually
gonna do the exact same
thing we did before so i'm gonna find
the max
from the small heap in o of one time i'm
gonna remove that max so
seven is removed to remove we know it
takes login time
and then i'm going to add it to the min
heap
which also takes log n time so now
i'm adding seven and the lengths are
approximately equal still right this has
one element this has
two elements and now if we get the
maximum from here
two and we get the min from here three
we see that the condition actually now
is true every element in the left
is less than or equal to every element
in the right
now we added seven now let's do add four
so by default i'm always going to add it
to the small heap
so i'm adding four to the small heap the
small heap has two
the large g has two also but we know
that
this condition doesn't hold right the
less than or equal condition if we get
the max
from here that's going to be four if we
get the min from here that's going to be
three
this is just not true right four is not
less than or equal to three
so we have to pop this and we have to
move it
to this heap so now everything is good
right it's
every value is less than or equal write
this as two this has three that's less
than or equal gray
only problem now is the lengths are not
approximately equal
this has one element this has three
elements
so since the length of this one is
greater what are we gonna do we're gonna
get we're gonna find the min
o of one time remove that min and
then move it to this heap so we know
that the min
is three we can do that in o of one time
but removing it is gonna be
log n and adding it to the left heap is
also gonna be log n
so now the lengths are approximately
equal this has two elements
this has two elements and the other
condition find the max from here find
the min here
we'll end up with three and four and
less than or equal is definitely true
so it looks like a lot of work and it
definitely is
it's a lot harder than just having one
array right
it's definitely more code but it's also
a lot more efficient now
the only thing we have to do is get the
median and
the time complexity for get median is
actually still
o of one which is exactly what we wanted
let me show you why
well we need in this case we have an
even number of elements right
two plus two is even so we wanna find
the maximum from our left heap which is
three right we know we can do that in
o of one time because this is a max heap
we want to find the minimum value from
our right heap and we know we can do
that in o of one time because this is a
min heap and we know that four happens
to be the min value
so we get these two values three plus
four
add them together divide by two and
that's going to be our median so we can
still
find the median in o of one time which
is great
now with all that being said let me
finally show you the code
and show you that it's not as long as
you might expect okay so now let's look
at the code
so here's a couple comments we're gonna
have two heaps large and small
large is gonna be a min heap mac or
small is gonna be a max heap
and the heaps should be roughly equal to
roughly
the same size so in python you can
actually have a heap
be just a list and i'll show you the
other things we'll need to do later so
actually in python since these are
members
of this object large and small we need
to
have a self as the prefix and so
now we have two functions to implement
find median and add num let's start with
add num
so just like i showed you what i'm going
to do is
i'm always going to take num and add it
to the small heap so
heap q dot heap push this is how you do
it in python
other languages might be different
obviously so to the small heap we're
going to push num
now python is kind of annoying in that
it only
implements min heaps we know small is
actually a
max heap so to get around that what i'm
going to
have to do is take every number and
actually multiply it by negative one
this allows us to actually implement a
max heap which
isn't implemented by default in python
for some reason
but what i'm doing here is taking num
and adding it to
the small heap the max heap right but
now we want to make sure
every element in small
is less is less than or equal to
every element in large right so every
element in the small heap has to be less
than or equal to every element in the
large heap so i'm going to make sure
that that's true so
if if small and large are non-null
and so from from small from our
small heap our max heap what i'm going
to do is get the max value from it so
how can i do that i can just take the
index of 0 because it's
implemented as a list heaps are
implemented as lists
so if you get the 0th index you're
getting the max value
we know that every time we add a value
to the small heap we're multiplying it
by negative one
so to reverse that i'm going to take
this value
and multiply it by negative one and get
the true value that we actually added to
the heap
and so i wanna know is this value
somehow
greater than the smallest value in our
large heap how can i get the smallest
value in our large heap i can do the
exact same thing
index of zero but i didn't have to
multiply this by negative one
because this is a min heap and that's
what python does by default
so if this condition is true let me make
it look a little nicer so
so that mainly this condition is true
meaning that some value
in our our small heap is greater than
our large heap then we have to
pop from our small heap and then add to
our large heap
so i'm going to heap q dot
heap pop so i'm going to pop from our
small heap i'm going to get the largest
value from our small heap stored in val
and then i'm going to i'm going to push
that value
to our large heap so to our large heap
i'm going to push that value
basically exactly what i did in the
picture but maybe the
code is a little confusing oh and
actually since we know
every value pushed to the small heap is
being multiplied by negative one
to reverse that we have to also multiply
it by negative one when we pop from it
because look when we pushed to it we
multiplied that number by negative one
but to our large heap we can actually
give the correct values we don't have to
multiply by negative one
that is actually probably one of the
more confusing parts about this
which is annoying because there's no way
to really get around it in python
so now we check this condition the only
other condition that we have to check
is what if the size is uneven
and so by uneven size we actually mean a
difference
greater than one so if the length of
small
is greater than the length of large plus
one that means the difference is two or
greater
in that case in that case what are we
going to do this is too big so what
we're going to do is
pop from the small and then up and then
push to the large which is actually
exactly what we did
up here so i'm just going to copy and
paste that
and the other case is if the length
of the large heap is greater than the
length of the small heap
plus one meaning the difference is two
or greater
and in that case i'm basically going to
do the opposite of what we just did up
here so let me copy and paste that so
we don't need this negative one because
we are going to be popping from
the large heap which has the correct
values not the negative one multiplied
values
and with that value though i'm going to
take that value and add it to the
small heap and actually we are going to
need to take this value and then
multiply it by negative 1
because we have to do that whenever we
add to this
small heap so now we are making sure we
take every element add it to one of the
heaps and if there happens to be
a size difference we're handling that if
there happens to be
an order difference right like the
values are in the wrong order we're
handling that as well
and remember all of these heap
operations are
log n operations log n
and now the last thing we have to handle
is finding the median
so one case is that there's an odd
length how do we know if there's an odd
length well
if the length of small was ever
greater than the length of large we know
that then we have an
odd length right because maybe one of
them has three elements the other has
two elements
we know with this function we're always
making sure that they're
about roughly equal so if this evaluated
true that means we have an odd number of
elements
and small happens to have an extra
element so what we can do
is return the largest value in small
which is stored in index 0 of small
if the opposite is true if the length of
large
is somehow greater than the length of
small
we know that the opposite happens to be
true so we can return
the smallest value in large now if
neither of these
evaluates that means we have an even
number of elements so
each each of these heaps has the exact
same size so what we can do in that case
is return the largest value
in the small heap plus the smallest
value in the large heap add them
together
and then divide by two and then return
the result of that
so here is the final code it's 34 lines
but you can see we have some comments
and some
you know boilerplate type uh code
but the code that itself that we had to
write was relatively short right because
we did this with a heap
and we did it pretty efficiently let me
just run it to prove that it works
okay uh just one time i forgot to
say that this small is a member object
so self.small
and i actually forgot to do that in a
couple places so let me just fix that so
self.small self.large self.small
self.large self.small self.large
and a couple more places okay so we
corrected
the self errors one last thing i forgot
is remember
small as negative we multiplied the
numbers by negative so when we're
getting the number and actually trying
to calculate the median we have to take
that number and multiply it by negative
one
before we add it to this number and then
divide by two
and let me not forget to do the exact
same calculation when we're returning
the value here right so i somehow had
too many bugs in here but okay so now
finally
this should be the final code the big
thing in python at least is to remember
these negative ones if you're doing this
in c
plus plus or java i'm pretty sure you
will not have to worry about that
this should be the final code finally
and you can see
yes it is pretty efficient and in python
at least it's not
a lot of code i think even in java and c
plus it shouldn't be that much code
either so i hope this was helpful
if you enjoyed please like and subscribe
it supports the channel
a lot and i'll hopefully see you pretty
soon